Gisèle Robidoux à 86 ans et elle est
atteinte de la maladie pulmonaire
obstructive chronique avec le smoke des
derniers jours ces symptômes sont pires
qu'elle habitude on est belle de
souffler et puis j'ai pas dans le sang
j'ai pas pu faire mes exercices
aujourd'hui ils t'ont à Gatineau qu'à
Montréal l'indice de la qualité de l'air
représente un risque très élevé pour la
santé c'est aussi le cas dans les
Laurentides Lanaudière la Mauricie et la
région de Québec c'est juste le
contraire de la covid la covid en
emportait pas dehors en apportant
la différence pour elle je ferais pas
comme une longue sortie de 20 km
aujourd'hui
sont réduits à 1$ pour encourager le
recours aux transports collectif et
diminué le nombre de voitures sur les
routes la santé publique de Laval
recommande aux élèves et aux personnels
scolaires de demeurer à l'intérieur
autant que possible même pendant l'heure
du dîner et les récréations à Montréal
on demande aux écoles d'être vigilantes
on voit s’assurer le de garder nos
fenêtres ouvertes pour la qualité de
l'air avec les lecteurs de CO2 mais si
on y a des enfants qui se plaignent que
ça leur picote dans la gorge ou que les
yeux leur paix qu'on va peut-être les
refermer
des matchs et des pratiques de baseball
et de soccer amateurs chez les jeunes
sont annulés dans la grande région de
Montréal mais on peut s'attendre un
risque exacerbé pour notre santé donc
c'était documenté dans l'altération
médicale c'est souvent des gens qui ont
des problèmes cardiaques ou
respiratoires qui vont avoir des
complications de ça donc désinfections
des crises d'asthme il y a des gens qui
vont faire des infarctus qui vont avoir
besoin de consulter à l'urgence partant
de smog la santé publique du Québec
recommande le plus possible de limiter
nos activités extérieures et de porter
un masque pour diminuer notre exposition
aux particules fines produites par les
feux de forêt ici Gabriel pro
Radio-Canada Montréal